so out of anything you could possibly do
for your health
fasting and intermittent fasting
are the most important things you can do
there's nothing else that even comes
close
in creating more health now on the flip
side
snacking and continued eating is the
worst thing you can do for your health
so today i'm going to show you the
basics of how to do intermittent fasting
actually it's not necessarily just for
the beginners it's for advanced people
too because i found that if you're
running into a plateau or things aren't
going as smooth
you need to go back to the basics all
right let's get into the meat potatoes
of fasting well we probably shouldn't
talk about potatoes how about the meat
in cauliflower of fasting what we're
trying to do is we're trying to go from
sugar burning
to
fat burning a big confusion that a lot
of people have when they're fasting is
they think their body is starving they
think it's not eating but in reality
your body is eating when it's not eating
it's finally eating its own fat
that is why
the best indicator to know that it's
working
is your appetite
gone okay if your appetite is going away
and you don't have any more appetite
you're not hungry anymore guess what
it's working and it makes it a lot
easier to stick to if you don't have an
appetite
so
the principle that i've talked about in
other videos is you have to get healthy
to lose weight not lose weight to get
healthy that means that we're not
necessarily focused on weight loss
weight loss will come
after you get healthy but a better
indicator for success is your ability to
fast
comfortably because you're not hungry
like right now it's 12 o'clock noon i
haven't eaten since yesterday at about 6
30 am i hungry i'm not hungry i am
absolutely not interested in any food at
all i don't want to eat anything right
now the first meal that i have will be
roughly about 3 3 30 today and even then
i could probably fast longer just
because i've been doing it for a long
time but you want to get into a
condition where the food is no longer
controlling you you're controlling your
food
so many people are into this
situation where the food is literally
controlling their life and it's
destroying their life all right so the
first thing you need to do is skip
breakfast okay or start to push your
breakfast further further
towards lunch okay so when you wake up
in the morning ask yourself are you
really hungry or are you just eating out
of habit
chances are you're not going to be
hungry for breakfast so don't eat so the
rule of thumb is don't eat if you're not
hungry okay now to help you not be
hungry
for breakfast you have to make sure that
you keep your carbs down for your lunch
and your dinner because if you have
carbs in your lunch or your dinner guess
what the next day
you're going to be hungry
in the morning but if you keep your
carbs low and i'm talking about roughly
about maybe 20 grams maybe 30 grams
then you're not going to be hungry in
the morning
the other thing that you can do is you
can also do the bulletproof coffee you
can add either butter to your coffee or
mct oil butter is very satisfying and
mct oil will turn into ketones so it's
going to be a lot easier to go all the
way up until your first meal at noon so
depending on if you drink coffee or not
if you don't drink coffee just do a
tablespoon of mct oil that's the type of
extract from coconut oil that turns into
ketones very very fast so the other
thing you have to realize is that
all these hormones are on rhythms or
waves okay and the cortisol hormone
peaks at eight o'clock in the morning so
you may find
that you're
hungry in the morning because of a
cortisol spike but you're not really
hungry it's just a hormonal
shift and a sensation that you get
so the next thing i'm going to recommend
is if you have this
minor hungry feeling just ignore it
ignore the
hunger nine times out of ten it will go
away okay and that's just because
there's certain hormonal shifts
happening in the body
that are creating that sensation but
just ignore it
now if you ignore it and it doesn't go
away and you feel
dizzy tired weak then you need to eat
but you really need to be able to tell
the difference between
hunger and time to eat but realize as
you start doing this it's going to get
easier and you won't have any hunger in
the morning unless you consume
carbohydrates all right the next little
thing i'm going to say is at this
first meal
make sure you add some fat at the end of
the meal that can be pecans or olives or
some nut butter it could be peanut
butter it could be brie cheese it could
be fatty meat it could be any of those
why do you want to add fat because when
you start doing intermittent fasting you
haven't adapted yet and so you need the
fat to help you go longer to feel
satisfied so you can fast longer because
the fasting itself
and the combination of low carbs is
really what's going to help you start to
adapt to this new machine in your cells
that's burning fat
so the same thing with dinner you want
to add fat at the end of the meal now
the next point i want to bring up is
this
whole thing about healthy keto okay what
is healthy keto well
healthy keto is not just going on a low
carb it's using quality foods that are
higher in nutrients because the last
thing you want to do is end up looking
like a crack head and i'm being very
sarcastic but some people when they lose
weight they they sort of look
very unhealthy their hair is dried out
they look older we want you to look good
as you do the ketogenic diet and look
younger
okay have that healthy glow so that's a
combination of low carb
fasting and just healthier ingredients
so there's such a thing as dirty keto
where you're not paying attention to the
quality and you're
eating at a fast food restaurant or fast
food and yeah it's low carb because
you're not eating the bun but it's very
very low quality food don't recommend
that all right so this first meal and
second meal is called your eating window
okay so let's just pretend
your first meal is at noon and your
second meal is at six o'clock so that
would be roughly a six hour eating
window now
when you first start out
you could potentially eat
during this window through here okay
have a snack if you want but i would
recommend or challenge you to not do
that because that way we get some
fasting between these meals too and that
will help you the snacking is the
biggest
killer for
progress because the snack stimulates
insulin every time you eat you stimulate
this thing called insulin and what we're
trying to do is fix insulin resistance
which was created by a high level of
insulin for a long period of time which
comes from constant eating and eating a
lot of carbohydrates now if you do a six
hour eating window that gives you an
18-hour
fasting cycle that's pretty good if you
could do
18 hours of fasting
you're going to see some amazing results
especially with your brain you're going
to grow new brain cells and so your
cognitive function your focus your
memory your ability to keep your
attention your creativity all is going
to improve as well as your mood you're
going to be happier if you were
depressed you're going to feel much much
better just because your brain is
healing plus your immune system is going
to get stronger you actually grow new
immune stem cells in your bone marrow
which is really cool inflammation goes
way down and you start getting
rejuvenated you start healing faster all
sorts of amazing things happen all right
so now here's another
problem we need to resolve
at night okay
i know this might be hard to believe but
there are some people out there that
have a hard time not snacking at night
now we're not talking about you you
probably know people or friends or
family members but this snacking at
night has to go
it's called grazing i was a professional
snacker at night i would basically
after dinner
eat constantly until i went to bed it
was constantly putting things in my
mouth
and you know nuts apples
chips you name it that was me so popcorn
oh my gosh
and that that's very very bad so
we want to
get rid of the snacking how do we do it
well
we use what's called self discipline we
have to make sure we don't buy any
snacks anymore so they're not available
to us you want to stay busy because if
you're idle and just sitting there maybe
watching tv it's going to be more
difficult
but i really think that what's going to
help you
is this dinner making sure that you have
a very big
dinner with this fat so you're actually
really full and you don't feel the need
for any additional things but just
realize
if you're like me and everyone else you
probably have insulin resistance which
means you can't absorb
nutrients as well as you should so even
though you eat and you're full you might
not feel satisfied there's a difference
feeling satisfied is going to happen
once the insulin resistance goes away
and especially if you're eating a lot of
nutrient dense foods there are some
things you can do
that will also improve that one point
apple cider vinegar okay maybe a
tablespoon in your water
for dinner
apple cider vinegar has acetic acid
the biggest benefit of acetic acid is to
make insulin more sensitive to help your
blood sugars so it's going to actually
help you reduce insulin that's why it
can help you lose weight but it'll also
help your appetite it'll help actually
insulin work better so you absorb more
nutrients and you'll be less
hungry so apple cider vinegar in your
water is really good i would also while
you're at it add some lemon to your
water lemon juice okay
maybe
a teaspoon maybe a half of a lemon maybe
a whole lemon this way you can have
things like vitamin c if it's fresh or
citric acid that can help reduce kidney
stones and if you're at risk for gout
because sometimes when you're doing
fasting your uric acid goes up which
acts as an antioxidant but it can flare
up gout so
just add the lemon and apple cider
vinegar in your water when you drink
this
for dinner another suggestion
are these things called
vegetables okay
i highly recommend you consume more
vegetables so i'm talking about like a
big salad
i will do my big salad
either in the first meal
or the second meal now my my meal
is actually about right here so i might
eat at three and then at six so i have a
very very short indie eating window it's
hard for me to eat all the calories in
one meal so i spread it out within like
maybe three maybe four hours but that's
just me i just want to focus right now
on not necessarily going beyond this 18
and 6 but let's say you're eating at 12
and 6. to make it easy you can add a
salad right here a seller right here or
you can just have a very big salad the
salad that you eat
should be
eaten in the beginning of the meal why
because if you eat the protein first i
have found that the chances of you
eating that salad are going to be slim
to none because
you're now filled up with the protein so
i always recommend eat the salad first
and then eat your protein in fat second
it seems to work
but again that's just a minor point now
why do we need to sell it well it's
going to give you
more potassium and magnesium which is
going to help
that insulin problem i talked about
also it's going to give you energy also
it's going to prevent cramping in your
legs
and it's going to prevent keto fatigue
etc etc
the fiber in the vegetables
feeds the microbes
and that's what the microbes live on so
you're feeding your microbes they get to
eat something and then what they do is
they change it into a type of fat
which actually is really good for your
blood sugars
so
i found that if i don't consume large
salads that i don't feel quite right in
fact it's harder to get into keto and
it's not going to go as smooth
also the vegetables are really good for
your liver and you're just going to feel
cleaner if you do that
and you can switch it out you can have
just vegetables okay sometime or just a
salad other time if you do the
vegetables you don't need the quantity
you don't need 10 cups of like broccoli
right so you do smaller maybe half the
amount and then
for salad because it's not as dense
you can have more of that the salads the
apple cider vinegar eating more fat at
the end of the meal is going to help you
avoid this
snacking now i want to just mention
something about cholesterol because um
this question keeps coming up over and
over and over and over again what
happens if my cholesterol goes up it
happens with a percentage of the
population usually it goes down but in
some people it goes up like my wife and
people are concerned they go to the
doctor and like oh my gosh my
cholesterol is high because i'm eating
all this fat well if you really
understand what's happening it's not
going to be that scary because
when you burn fat
a certain portion of that fat
is cholesterol so it's composed of
triglycerides which you use for
energy but also cholesterol which you
don't use for energy you don't burn
cholesterol so the cholesterol and the
fat has to come out has to go somewhere
right i mean the whole goal is to burn
your fat reserve so we have to get the
cholesterol out somehow so it has to go
through this thing called the liver
okay it comes to the liver
and if you don't have enough
liver function or you don't have enough
bile
for some reason let's say you don't have
a gallbladder or let's say if you have a
fatty liver and you're not producing
enough bile
then you may have a little backup of
cholesterol so the more bile you have
the easier it is for your body to get
rid of this excess cholesterol but even
the fact that your cholesterol is high
and you don't have the bile to break it
down or get rid of it as fast as you
would like
realize if you went to do an advanced
lipid profile test
and you found that you have high ldl
there's a couple different types of ldl
and you're going to find that the high
ldl that you have
is the large particle size it's not the
small dense
type of ldl so the small dense type is
the dangerous one you're not going to
find that
you're only going to find that if you're
doing high carbs okay so i wouldn't
worry about it but if you are concerned
you can do the test and you can see for
yourself
and i included a video of my own wife
having high ldl and i explained that
thoroughly now the other thing that i
want to mention which is the icing on
the cake or well i probably shouldn't
talk about cake but when you do
intermittent fasting in keto together
within 14 days
50
of the fat in your liver is going to be
gone that is huge that is exciting
as long as you don't eat that icing on
the cake of course all right a couple
other things i'm going to show you about
this fasting thing
green tea
very very very awesome to
drink through the day because green tea
helps insulin resistance okay it'll
allow you to fast longer
now there's other types of tea
or herbs that are in tea that are also
really good for blood sugars that will
help reduce appetite
like green tea will like cinnamon tea
using the herb garcinia
ginseng ginger
are all really good to lower your
appetite so that's just an extra little
tip
if you exercise okay i'm going to
recommend you not do any type of
pre-workout drink with a carbohydrate or
even protein
i wouldn't recommend any post drink or
taking any amino acids while you're
working out before or after why
because here you are you just worked out
and you created this amazing effect with
growth hormone and as soon as you start
eating something you basically kind of
nullify a lot of those results
especially if it's carbohydrate and even
if it's protein okay you're doing some
protein powder so
realize as far as the nutrients
around that exercise especially amino
acids you're going to get enough amino
acids from the meals okay so you don't
worry about putting back these amino
acids because really most of them tend
to even just turn the sugar like the
branch amino acids so i wouldn't
recommend eating around that exercise
keep your fasting consistent okay
the other point i want to bring up is
supplements
when people fast a lot of times they
have symptoms like keto fatigue keto flu
they might get cramps they might have
thyroid symptoms
all that means is that
you're probably deficient in certain
nutrients because the demand for certain
nutrients go higher and maybe you
haven't been eating nutrient dense foods
for a while so
what you need to do is just
make sure you just take b vitamins
natural ones i recommend nutritional
yeast
and electrolytes and i would recommend
an electrolyte powder that also has
trace minerals i'll put a link down
below of the one that i recommend
that way you can get the trace minerals
and the electrolyte minerals
with high amounts of potassium which is
going to help you potassium is needed in
large amounts in the body i'm talking
like 4 700 milligrams so
sometimes if you can't do a lot of salad
this is a good little backup plan but if
you do the supplements okay with
intermittent fasting and especially
prolonged fasting
you can easily avoid keto fatigue
keto flu thyroid symptoms all right so
now let me just cover a couple mistakes
that people make
a small snack let's say you're doing
keto
and
you're like you're on a roll i'm just
gonna fast all day long so instead of
um
doing the fasting and waiting to your
big meal
i'm just gonna do maybe a little snack
just to kind of push me through thinking
that
doing a little snack or lower calories
is going to get me by and i'll be fine
with that but realize that
this snacks
especially the protein ones like if you
did like a scoop of peanut butter for
example you what's gonna happen is
you're gonna spike insulin
it's a protein protein triggers insulin
not as much as carbs but it will
and then guess what about an hour and a
half you're gonna be hungry it's going
to throw you off your plan
so there's really only two things
that won't stimulate insulin
fiber
and fat
protein will
so if you have to snack on something
do either pure fat as in like mct oil
okay or that bulletproof coffee
or
fiber
something very fibrous
like celery for example without the
peanut butter or some greens okay now
some of you are going like i'm not going
to do that because that's not very
pleasurable but i'm just telling you
that a mistake that people make is doing
this little protein snack as i interview
people and find out why it's not working
um i find out there well i'm sort of
doing keto with a couple little snacks
for the day and that type of thing so
just realize that that's why your
results are not going to be where you
need to be them i'm just bringing this
up as a
as a point these small snacks are killer
okay
even if they're
healthy
okay the next
little thing that i want to bring up is
that
the awareness of a little bit of carb
and what that does
to the state of ketosis if you're trying
to lose weight if you're trying to get
into a really good fasting state
and
and you're going along
and
let's say at night you do i'm just going
to do a little wine it's not many
calories whatever or let's say during
the day you're going to do just like one
piece of bread
what you have to realize is that a
little bit of carb
can block you
as far as knocking you out of ketosis
for a good amount of time
half a glass of wine could knock you out
of ketosis for 24 hours
a couple drinks on the weekend
that whole weekend you're not going to
be burning any fat or you're not going
to be in ketosis just realize that
i'm not telling you not to do it i'm
just
the messenger
giving you the information
that if you do it don't be surprised if
the results are not what you want them
to be okay
because sometimes people are just
thinking of calories they're not looking
at the hormone effects of different
types of food all right the next point i
want to bring up is this
this idea
that it's all going to happen really
quick
maybe
you have a friend or a family member
that does this and it happens really
quick for them but for you
it's not happening
i had a guy
that did my
program
many years ago i didn't really educate
him that well
and he says yeah your program didn't
work i said what do you mean yeah i did
it for two weeks and it didn't work i
said what happened well it did work for
two weeks but then i stopped doing it
but then it didn't keep working
i'm like
what
i said
this is not a short-term thing where
it's just gonna fix your weight problem
now you can go back to your old plan
this is like
a lifelong change
a new lifestyle
process or habit that you need to
do consistently for the rest of your
life okay
and that was something that i just
needed to educate him on because of this
point the number of years
that an average person has eaten poorly
and including myself in this group
has been
a long time okay we've developed this
condition called insulin resistance
it's become very very chronic okay it's
a bad problem
and
the time it takes to fix it
is much greater than what you may think
the level of effort is going to be a lot
more than what you think so you want to
give it time you don't want to focus on
just the weight you want to focus on the
appetite energy cognitive improvements
decrease inflammation
that means it's working because you're
creating your health
so
this is why you have to have patience
this is why we call you a patient and
this is why we have also a waiting room
last point i want to bring up
this
false piece of information that we've
been
told so many times
everything in moderation
just a little bit is fine
there's no bad food
just keep everything in balance it's all
about balance no that is not true when
you're trying to get healthy you don't
want to balance everything
there's things that are really important
and there's things that are trivial not
very important at all what i'm showing
you here
is the most important thing you can do
for your health out of anything and that
is fasting and i'm also showing you the
food that you need to avoid the most
which is a carbohydrate and the other
foods that you can eat in higher amounts
like fat
and there is one food that you want to
eat in moderation that's protein right
so to get someone healthy they're
already in an out of balance state okay
so to put more
balance and just balance everything out
and eat a little bit of everything is
the worst advice that anyone can give
you
so i've just given you the things that
you should focus
the most of your attention on when
getting healthy
and now your next step is to learn on
what to eat and that's in this video
right here check it out